week after week the world of call of
duty continues to provide us
with funny moments 200 iq plays and a
little dash of what them
this week we're bringing you five
moments that show off a little bit of
everything
let's get into it number five
revived by falling that's right this
first clip not only shows what true
friendship looks like
but it does it with some serious style
after being down to topa stadium
feed the pony up here crawls to the edge
and hopes to get revived by his buddy
irish keep below
well seeing as how the fall damage here
could kill anyone at this range
what happens next is a hilarious miracle
that these two won't ever forget
[Music]
hearing these guys quietly crack up
after this incredible save is what it's
all about
number four shotgun stowaway landing
into a fresh round of war zone is
stressful enough
but imagine finding a whole another team
and hopping into the truck bed alongside
of them
think they'll notice let's find out
no they don't our friend taco tornado
here takes full advantage of the
situation and wipes them
out
[Music]
hearing those death comes afterwards was
the icing on the cake
unfortunately taco couldn't have his
cake and eat it too as he's down by
something as the gas rolls in at hyper
speed
rest easy taco you did good man
number three ammo box legend being
chased down by not one but two riot
shielders is intimidating to say the
least
but without a molotov or thermite what
can you do fortunately for fahad here
his quick thinking got him out of a
sticky situation
in this amazing two-for-one clutch how
you ask
with an ammunitions box and a whole lot
of guts
not a big fan of tea bagging myself but
my god that felt 100
necessary number two
you okay charlie season four gave us
this earth expeditionary force pack with
an all-new
charlie skin and oh my goodness to be
fair this isn't the first time this has
ever happened
but leave it to tarmac bbq to really let
it sink in
i mean it gets a little better the
longer we wait but the damage is done
and i'll never play as charlie again oh
you're not dead man you are
number one the stealth soldier pete here
is far from his friends and has taken
hold in the small office
unfortunately some unwanted visitors
make their way in too
no worries though they don't see him
seriously they have no idea pete's here
even after some commotion let's watch
[Music]
if you like what you saw and want to
submit a clip yourself hit me up on
twitter
richie's that's me with the burrito
until then stay tuned for more call of
duty videos coming soon
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you